[Music]
[Applause]
in this video I'm gonna teach you how to
overcome any fears that you have of
public speaking and how to find that
inner lioness rule did you know that
this fear of public speaking that we all
have it's like the fifth biggest fear in
the world what it stems from usually is
a moment in childhood or your early
years where you felt judged or
criticized for making a mistake usually
you're in the classroom four or five
years old you're learning to read out
loud for the first time you mess up a
word you make a mistake and it forms a
little scar inside your psyche and then
as you go through life every time you
mess up a word or you say a wrong thing
or you get told off or judged or
criticized in some way it all adds up
and creates this big wound which creates
a fear of public speaking now and as
you're getting onto stage or as you're
in an office boardroom or whatever it is
when you need to share learnings or
teachings in some way your whole brain
and nervous system goes into a panic
reaction when that happens and you get
the sweaty palms and you get those
anxiety feelings in your body try this
simple tool it's genius
it's called tapping and I'm going to
invite you to go straight in with me and
tap along with me right now I'd like you
to take one of your hands I am
right-handed so I use my right hand
three fingers of it to tap on the
outside edge of my left hand if you're
left-handed it's the reverse and I'd
like you to join in with me when I'm
saying these phrases so you're tapping
on the outside edge of your hand even
though I have this fear of speaking out
loud
and it scares the hell out of me I
deeply and completely accept Who I am
and how I feel
repeat after me even though the thought
of public speaking makes me petrified I
deeply and completely accept Who I am
and how I feel even though I'm so afraid
of this work I've got to present I
deeply and completely accept Who I am
and how I feel now take two fingers of
the hand you've just been tapping on and
tap on the beginning of either eyebrow
I'm really afraid right now tapping on
the side of the eye I've got so much
fear
tapping under the eye I'm so afraid of
what I've got to talk about tapping on
the top lip what if I make a mistake
tapping on the chin here
what if I mess something up take your
hand into her face and gently tap on the
collarbone here and I get it all wrong
armour tapping on your bra strap here
what if I mess it up top head
what if I lose my job keep going
two fingers eyebrow again I'm really
afraid at this thing I've got to present
side of the eye what if I mess up all
the words under the eye what if I forget
what I have to talk about top lip I feel
so worried right now chin I'm so scared
about getting up there turned into a
fist collarbone what if I mess it all up
underneath the arm bra strap here what
if I get it all wrong
top of the head the thought of doing
this makes me feel really anxious take a
really nice big deep breath in and
release it let it go
that should make you feel much of karma
if you feel you need to keep tapping
rewind this video and tap along with me
a few more times I look forward to
teaching you more in the next video
[Music]